I've got something to say.
Comedy Central now has
a youtube channel
just for stand-up.
Here's a new rule. Nobody
needs to wake up gangster in the
morning.
Bing. Yo, (bleep) this (bleep).
Find exculsive clips
you won't see anywhere else.
Here you are,
you're welcome peasants.
With the hottest comedians
of today.
Back to the regular porn.
And the hottest
comedians of today,
way before today.
I got some stuff in the trunk
you ain't never seen before,
buddy.
It's an awesomely big collection
of stand-up.
Oh, is it? You're so big?
The Comedy Central Stand-Up
YouTube channel.
First round's on me.
With new videos every Monday and
Friday.
Wow.
Subscribe now.
I sure would like to.